hi there today we're talking about
nystrom former
a nice germ-based algorithm for
approximating self-attention
by yun young champang chang
rudrazis chakraborty ming xing tan
glen fung
so this paper yet another paper that
proposes
a approximation to the self-attention
mechanism to the self-attention matrix
in
transformer models this time it's based
on the
nystrom matrix approximation that's why
the model
is called nystrom former and
why it is not called the nystromer
i don't know like you had you had the
chance so i'm officially
renaming this to the
knife streamer okay
that's the that's the title now that's
the model now the nice dreamer
by the way if you're not in any language
that has
this sign or this sign it's called an
so you go oh but
well it's hard to explain in any case
as i said this is an approximation to
the self-attention matrix
the nicer method basically takes a
subset of
rows and columns uh sorry of keys and
queries in this case
and approximates the full matrix by
uh just using this subset um and
we're going to look at how this works
but the promise is that you can scale
transformers to much longer sequences
without having the
classic attention bottleneck that you'd
have in transformers
and the results so far show are pretty
good for this model
though results in single papers you know
how i feel
about those but we'll check it out we'll
go through it
if you have comments let me know in the
comments
and don't hesitate to share the video
out if you like
content like this all right let's dive
in so there is a long discussion here
about transformers and
this this kind of bottleneck this
quadratic memory bottleneck
and if you don't know what i'm talking
about you can go watch the video on
attention is all you need or any of the
transformer
videos the paper really starts down here
with the introduction of self-attention
so here we're dealing with
self-attention
there is also something like cross
attention
like when you have an encoder and a
decoder and you need to pass information
from the encoder to the decoder
that is not self attention that is
called something like cross
attention or i don't actually even know
what it's called
this model this paper deals with
self-attention though
um i know that lucid reigns and clash
look on twitter
had a nice conversation about how you
could do this
also for cross attention i'll i'll link
to it
uh check both of these people out um
yeah all right so self tension
you have your input your input signal
this is one
attention layer right it's usually
multi-head attention but here we'll just
have one
head so you have your retention layer
which takes an input x so your x
is usually some kind of a sequence and
you want to transform it into another
sequence so we've been here
a bunch of times already and you want to
know
it's probably an equally long sequence
you want to know
which information do you need to pass
where
so maybe this thing needs to inform
those two
and this thing needs to inform those
three
and this thing just needs to inform that
one and so on so
you you sort of want to transfer
transform a sequence into
another sequence in the next higher
layer and
yeah you want to kind of send
information around so that every
sequence element knows about every other
relevant sequence element the way you do
this is
by attention so what you do is you
construct these
query key and value matrices
of the attention mechanism simply by
linear projection so you can see that
the x here is an input to all of them
what you do next is you
this is the crucial operation you
multiplies
the queries by the keys so
essentially what you do is you express
the keys are as are vectors and
basically every sequence element is
advertising
what it has to offer so the keys are
vectors
something like this so every sequence
element expresses a key
and the key is an encoding of what the
sequence at what kind of information the
sequence element contains
and then every sequence element also
expresses a query
and the query i usually draw up here and
that
is what kind of information would this
sequence element like to gather
from its surroundings right so and then
you do the
the inner product you multiply each
query by each key
and you can see already like this
element here
is probably going to receive information
from this and from this
because the inner product is very
high between the query that this
expresses
and the keys that these express and so
on so you can
see that you need to multiply each query
by each key
that's exactly this operation over here
query times keys and that gives you
a quadratic complexity in time and
memory basically so
you have usually your query matrix and
your query matrix
is number of sequence elements
so your query matrix is number of
sequence elements
times the number of dimensions so you
have
some kind of d dimensionality
for your queries and here
n is the sequence length right so you
have one query per
sequence element one row here is one
query
and then you have the keys and the keys
and usually write the keys as a
transposed matrix
are exactly the same so they are number
of sequence elements
times some kind of dimensionality inner
dimensionality now i'm
on purpose i'm already drawing the
dimensionality
smaller than the number of sequence
elements because that's usually the case
so the especially if you have multi-head
attention
the dimensionality can be lower or
is often lower than the number of
sequence elements
n right here and then you perform
this product and what you end up with is
as we said this
n by n matrix
so this is an n by n matrix and one
element in this matrix is going to be
the product of course of the
corresponding query
and key now
the well we'll get to the rank in just a
second
the second notable operation here is
this
softmax operation so after you've put
queries and keys together you want to
perform a soft max and that is a row
wise
softmax it says it down here a row wise
softmax
which means that in order to
uh really so this is this is this here
is simply
queries times keys this is not the
self-attention matrix yet
what you need to do is you need to put
it through a softmax
and in the softmax it's the same matrix
except it's normalized by rho right so
the soft max
is something like the soft max of x is
something like
um at position i
and like e to the x i divided by
sum over j e to the x j
right so you exponentiate every
element and then you normalize by the
whole row so this is the normalization
over the whole
row it's sort of like um
the softmax at the end of a classifier
where you just have a bunch of logits
right at the end of a classifier so if
this is your zero line you have a bunch
of logits one
says ah this is class is kind of likely
this one's not
this one's super likely but it's just a
bunch of numbers right your network's
gonna give you a bunch of numbers and
then
through the softmax you transform that
into a proper histogram
where you know this one is the highest
probability
this one a bit more and these two are
just really low probabilities
so the same softmax operation goes for
here because ultimately you want to know
from which point do you send information
where
and that is going to be a histogram that
is going to be a distribution
over so the the this
any sequence element sees
the input then as a distribution
over where it should gather input from
and how it should weigh
it when it aggregates it
people have tried this without the max
and it just turns out that it doesn't
work as well i guess in the future
someone might come up with something
that doesn't require normalization
but you know it is what it is right now
okay
so you need to normalize this
and you can see that in order to
normalize you actually need the whole
row so you need the whole row
to pass it through this softmax and that
is sort of the bottleneck if we could if
we were
if we didn't have the soft max right
here
a lot of techniques would apply a lot of
linear algebra techniques to decompose
this big matrix because
if you know a little bit about matrices
then you can immediate immediately see
that if this
d here if the dimensionality
is smaller than n then this
big matrix here will have a rank that's
lower than n
like it will have rank at most d and
that means that
you can decompose it into smaller parts
you can do a lot of tricks
to not have to deal with actually n by n
things however the soft max operation
requires you to consider these whole
rows at a time
and you can't really decompose it
because it's a non-linear operation and
that's
why so far people have struggled
approximating this now there are other
techniques like the performer and the
lin former and the long form actually
the long former is just local attention
but there are other techniques and i've
made videos about
most of them so what does this
paper do they find they they tackle the
problem again
of approximating this big matrix so
here is what they should suggest they
say
look what you can do
you can consider any matrix as sort of
this
collection of sub matrices so this
notation over here
it simply means that you want to divide
your matrix
into four sectors okay so you have
sector one here is
a and then this is b and then for some
reason this is
f and then this is c i don't know why
it's
f um we'll we'll just go with the flow
right here
okay so you can consider
any matrix like this and the goal here
isn't going to be
to actually do matrices that are
just evenly distributed the goal is
going to be
matrices that are distributed
where maybe something like this okay
so a is super small b and
f are kind of lo tall and wide
and c is a big block and our goal is to
be
to leave c away to simply store a b
and f and calculate with a b and f and
then
leave c and so so you can see if we can
do that
that is going to be an advantage
so the neister method does exactly that
it leaves away this c right here
leaves it away and replaces it by this
quantity
right here so if we have a
in the top left and then f and b on the
off diagonals
then we can reconstruct c and this seems
like magic
we can reconstruct c by f a
in a inverse b okay
and you can see it over here how you
would calculate something like this
you can immediately see that you don't
need this
this um you don't run into this
everything with everything bottleneck
because this right now
is simply this is n by m
and m is the size of a
and this is m by m and this here
is m by n so unless you
actually uh construct the full matrix
you don't need to
you don't need to worry about this
this n by n complexity because you can
just calculate with the smaller matrices
so there are two things right here if
you
we're we'll go into why this might work
in a second but there are two things
so the first thing is that i have just
said
that you can do all kinds of linear
algebra tricks
however in order to calculate the soft
max
you need to construct the full matrix
right that's what we said you need to
construct the n by n in order to
calculate
actually you just need to construct the
entire row but still
you need the full thing in order to
calculate the softmax
this linear algebra trick won't get us
around it
by itself and they actually say this
they say look if we if we do this and
they
this is the first kind of um
try at this if we do this we
would simply if we want to approximate
the soft max matrix
we would have to have the soft max
matrix first
in order to then select these sub
matrices from it
so we would need we would need to
calculate the
full rows in order to normalize them in
the softmax operation
before we can do these sub matrices
which would you know
defeat the purpose it would defeat the
purpose of
the whole thing so their
plan ultimately is going to be
you know when it's
it's something like this it is here you
have your
x you construct by means of keys queries
values you construct your um
sorry by means of keys and queries you
construct your matrix
um let's call it
you can oh sorry you construct your
matrix
s by
no let's call that what will we call it
you construct
let's call it keys queries queries keys
you construct this then you construct
the softmax matrix
and then you approximate it okay that is
the naive way
let's just say and then the neister
method comes in here
and you can see that you still need to
calculate the full
matrix before you can approximate it so
defeats the purpose
what they're going to do is simply
they're going to say well
can't we first approximate
sort of the the um
the queries and keys i'm just going to
make it like this
can we just approximate this somehow
and then do the and then from that
calculate the
softmax approximation and the neister
method would actually come
in somewhere here
that's where i'm not really convinced
because what they ultimately end up
doing
is they simply end up doing the
approximation inside the softmax
then applying the soft max to each of
the approximation
and then calculate with these
approximation
like this it's not really valid um
it's like saying here are two operators
that you really can't interchange
like you first need to construct this n
by n matrix
and only then can you apply the softmax
and they're just saying well
we're going to exchange the operators
anyway
um yeah so this this that's where the
approximation is
you exchange the operation of the soft
max
end of the sub sampling that is
necessary for the nice trim
approximation this
selecting rows and columns and um
they do have some proofs that this
converges to the true soft max matrix
but
just be aware that this is where the
approximation actually
happens in the exchange of operations
so this is the first thing the second
thing is why
why does this even work why does the
soft this nice term approximation even
work
and here is an intuition okay
so intuition number one we've already
said this
is low rank this is a low rank matrix
and
what does it mean to be low rank it
means that
um it means that
the entries in the matrix are not
necessarily
independent from each other so they
don't carry n
by n bits let's say of information right
here
or n by n floats even though the matrix
is n by n
large you can actually describe it with
less information that's what it means to
be
low rank and so it is conceivable
right that we can just leave away some
entries of the matrix
and recover them from the rest because
we already know that we don't need
the full numbers the full n by n numbers
to describe this matrix so if we somehow
had a handle
on the exact information we needed to
describe it we could leave away big
chunks now we might not have that so
okay so so what does the nystrom method
do
in this particular case now
let's leave away this soft max problem
for
for just a second and focus on what it
does
as we said we had our queries and
our keys as these kind of tall and long
matrices
right so the rows here are queries and
the columns here are keys
and we're about to do this outer product
now we don't we don't want to do this
outer product
but if we did we would get again this n
by
n matrix now the nicer method here
selects three matrices out of this
so first of all what it does is it
determines the so-called
landmarks and the landmarks are a subset
of queries and a subset of keys that are
special they're called landmarks now
actually
in this paper they calculate the
landmarks by averaging over
queries and keys but for easiness
we'll simply say we'll select a subset
so right now we're going to select
actually let's just
select one query and one
key as a landmark okay
so these are special in some way right
we'll see how they're special in a
second
so what we're going to do is we're going
to construct
first of all we're going to construct
two matrices right here we're going to
construct
the query tilde times the keys
and we're going to construct the queries
times the key tilde now the tilde
these are just the landmarks okay
so here you see that we're going to
calculate our attention matrices
but instead of um of calculating the
full attention
between all queries and alt keys we'll
simply calculate
the landmark query attention into all
the keys
right these are all
and we're going to calculate the
attention of the
landmark keys into all the queries
okay so we've now drastically reduced
because
instead of having you know all of the
queries and all keys
will simply have all keys with one query
and one key with
all queries so what does this give us
what can we accurately represent with
these things
well if we have one query
with all the keys right we can
accurately represent
this first row of the matrix right here
because that's a wiggly line
hope you can see that because you simply
take the landmark
query and you calculate its attention or
its
product its inner product with all of
the keys
which is exactly this first matrix right
here
we can also faithfully represent the
first column we can represent the first
column
accurately by well i am terrible today
because we have the first key and all
the queries its inner product with all
the queries
what we cannot accurately represent is
we cannot accurately represent any entry
down here in this big c matrix that we
not choose to leave away if we only
calculate these two matrices
we don't have any entries here okay
nada no so what
do we do if we actually want to know
what the an
entry here is well let's look what an
entry here represents
the entry here is the
interaction between query let's say
that's query
query five and key four
okay the key number four and query
number five we wonder
how do they relate to each other how it
what's their inner product kind of
how much are they attracted to each
other whatever you want to call it
and we don't know but what we can do
is we can ask so query five
and key four what's their inner product
and we can say well
we don't know what we do know however
is how does query 5
interact with key number one okay
so key number one
and query number one are the keys and
queries that we actually do have
and we do have the entry like this entry
right here for query five and key number
one we have
check we can calculate this and we can
also calculate another thing namely
so this we can calculate here and we can
calculate
how does key number four interact
with query number one okay we can also
calculate that
so how does key query number one
interact with key number four
check we can do that
and now what we simply need to do is we
need to know
how does key one and query one interact
you see we
have made kind of a a trip so instead of
um saying how does query 5 interact with
key four
we've asked how does query 5 interact
with key one
then we need to know how does key one
interact with
query one and from that how does query
one interact with
key four and via
kind of a way around here we have
determined the interaction between query
five and key four at least
in approximate so i hope you can see
that instead of going
directly from here to here
as we want it like we wonder how much
how how much you know weight how
here is a box this is a box
i want to lift it onto this shelf
and i want i wonder how much force
do i need to lift it onto this shelf now
what i can do
it can do this or i can ask well here
are a bunch of other shelves
um how much force do i need to lift it
onto this and then on to this
and then on to this now it's not going
to be exactly
the same because you know i every single
time i need to
put it down and pick it up again so
there is a bit of inaccuracy
but i'm going to get a pretty good idea
and that's the approximation so instead
of query 5 key 4
we're going to do query 5 key 1 query 1
key 4
and now since this is multiplicative
you can already see that here
technically
you know i would have i would have this
twice sort of because you can see the
two columns the column and the row are
overlapping in the top left corner
so what i actually need to do is i need
to divide
by the interaction query one sorry query
one
and key one okay this is a one
and now i have the correct approximation
um well is there even such a thing as a
correct approximation
that's a philosophical question in any
case that's how the nystrom method works
so instead of calculating the entries
directly it goes this
three-step way it says well i
don't have the entry so let me check
what
my the query i'm interested in does with
the landmark
keys and then i check
well what does the what do how do the
landmark
keys interact with the landmark queries
and then i check how do the landmark
queries interact with the key that i'm
interested in and from that i should be
able to determine
about how does the query i'm interested
in interact with the key i'm interested
in
and that now is the nice term
approximation
so the third matrix we actually need
right here is
we are going to need the queries times
the keys
of the landmark and we're going to
invert that
so it's either a pure inverse um or
actually what did what they do here a
pseudo inverse
just in case it is not invertible in
itself
so with these three matrices we can sort
of reconstruct the whole matrix
under the assumption that this is low
rank right
which it often is okay
you can see that's exactly what they do
so the
nice stream approximation is going to be
and this
is probably too pixel-ish but it's going
to be the
this oh now the query um
the interaction of all keys sorry all
queries
with the subset of keys then the
interaction just between the landmarks
and then the interaction between the
landmark
oh no this is query the landmark queries
and and all the keys
where you get the idea and
as i said they simply switch away the
operators
so what they do is they calculate each
of these inner matrices
right here you can see queries with
landmark keys
landmark queries with keys and landmark
queries with landmark keys
and then after they calculate this they
do
the soft max and after they do the soft
max
they multiply them together to get the
nice stream approximation
it's not valid because you need to do
the soft max
after right um or
before you even select the landmarks one
of the two so you
you can choose to nice to approximate
the
query times key matrix by itself
but then you need to cal you need to
reconstruct before you do the softmax
or you construct the full queries by
keys
do the softmax and then approximate
and then yeah you can decompose that but
again you need the full matrix and do
the softmax
this here is sort of an in between and
we're simply going to hope that this
gives us the good
matrix now of course they don't hope
they
actually in the supplementary material
they show the approximation
so here this lemma i just think it's
it's so funny
because what they say is well
the following simple result states that
the gallerkin discretization of the keys
and the queries with the same
set of quadrature and landmark points
induces the same
neister matrix in particular the same n
by m nistrem approximation
s this result agrees with the discussion
in
the dilemma is given the input
data set q and k and the corresponding
landmark point set
query tilden k tilde using 17
17 is what we've discussed so 17
is you have the softmax here then this
is this this inverse in the middle and
they have a
way of doing this pseudo inverse on on
kind of gpu
and then this is the other um
[Music]
the landmark queries with the keys
the nice term approximate self-attention
converges to the true self-attention
if there exists landmark points q tilde
and k tilde such
that and now check this out
such that the landmark is equal to
the query landmark query is equal to the
query
and the landmark key is equal to the
key for all i
and j so essentially
so they frame it as it suggests that if
the landmark points overlap sufficiently
with the original data points the
approximation to self-attention will be
good
well the lemma actually says if you
choose the original data points
as your queries and as your landmarks
then the approximation will be good and
i agree like if you choose
every single query every single key as
your landmarks
um your approximation will be good
because it won't be an approximation it
will actually just be the matrix you're
approximating
uh however in the supplementary material
which is
astonishingly difficult to find like i
it's on github
they do show the actual magnitude
of the approximation so you can see uh
here and here down here
they actually do have bounds on how bad
this approximation
is and it doesn't seem too bad
and yeah so the bounds are in terms of
the l infinity norm
uh so you can make use of the fact that
the soft max never goes over one and
things like
this right so there is a bit of math
behind it i just thought
it was it was funny because you know at
the end of the day
you do switch to operators that are kind
of not
so you can't really switch them
and um yeah but it appears to work
so i have also
uh if the authors are watching if the
authors are watching there is a mistake
where is the mistake where you discuss
so they discuss how they do the pseudo
inverse
yeah right here um
the say their algorithm converges to the
inverse
to this inverse this is the query tilde
key tilde yep and
i think here where we say let as be
approximated by
z star there should be an inverse right
here
probably all right so i hope you
got how they do this approximation
all right so they select the landmark
queries and the landmark keys they
then softmax the products between
landmarks and non-landmarks like this so
all of these three matrices
are much smaller than the original
matrix
they softmax max those individually and
then they calculate them together
in order to recover the full attention
matrix of course they never do this
explicitly because now
if you have three separate matrices and
there is and it's just a linear
operation
like this thing right here
then you can actually you can work with
them individually you never have to go
up into the full and by end dimensions
and they
do show this explicitly down here
so you can see that you have this kind
of
convoluted path but ultimately you have
your
input x you construct queries keys and
values then you select the landmark
points and they select as i said the
landmark points by
segment means that actually average out
landmark points uh sorry they average
out queries and keys to get the
landmarks
which i think is smarter than just
selecting a subset
um i don't know actually but it seems
okay
then they calculate this inner matrix
that they need to invert
right here this is m by m they also
calculate these
two uh long and tall
matrices then they calculate this thing
right here
which is n by m now if they were to
calculate it um together
with this it would give them back an
n by n they don't do it however they
first calculate
the product together with the values
which is ultimately what you want in
order to
reduce this dimensionality n right here
and then once they calculate that they
go into
they only have an n by d matrix they
also add a skip connection
down here to apparently stabilize
training or make it faster
they do say it works without this is
reminds me of the lambda layers
or lambda i don't know what it was
called
um but is is a similar reasoning you
never go to
n by n because if all of this are
linear algebra operations you can it is
valid
at this point to kind of switch the
order and do things
such that you never have to go up to the
full matrix
right so here is where they calculate
the means so you can see that the
landmarks are constructed by
averaging out a bunch of queries and
keys
and a last thing i wanted to mention
about this
is maybe an intuition of why
switching the softmax and
the order of operation here the thing i
said is not
valid why this might actually be valid
so assume um
why do you need why do you need the full
matrix for the softmax
because we said you have this row here
and you need to normalize over the whole
row it's valid right
because ultimately you want the
distribution to come out so
you need to normalize over everything in
the distribution
otherwise it won't be a valid
distribution
now you can see that this is pretty easy
for
one of these two right if we have
this thing right here if we have the
queries
the landmark queries and all the keys
that will give us a matrix
like this okay so
this is a different this is a different
matrix now than
the key matrix this is simply the
landmark
queries and i think i've drawn this if
we just have one landmark
let's actually have more one than one
landmark because i want to make my point
so here is landmark query one landmark
query two
and landmark query three right these are
the subset of queries we selected or
they are the averages of queries
right however you wanna do it and here
is key one
sorry key 2 and so on with all the keys
now we calculate this do we have a
problem here
with the soft max no we don't because
the soft max goes over the row
and in this matrix at least we can you
know
we have the whole row so we can
normalize across the row
not a problem this gives us a valid
distribution
for these particular queries
where we do get a problem is when we
have
this matrix this matrix is the tall
matrix and the tall matrix
is all the queries with the landmark
keys so here is query one query two
and so on and here is landmark key one
landmark key two and landmark key three
now we have a problem because if we want
to normalize by row
we're missing a whole bunch of keys
now why could this still work
now it could still work because as i as
we said
these things here they're actually the
means
of all the keys so this is the mean
of the first third of the keys this is
the
mean of the second third of all the keys
and so on
so that might be one reason but another
reason comes from
word embeddings so if you know word
embeddings then
you know that um if i want to train word
embeddings what i do is i say like
a cat sat on
the mat
and if i want to train word embeddings
one particular word to vec what i do is
i take a particular word
like this word here sat the word sat
and i try to predict
the surrounding words okay
so i try to predict the word cat
from sat now in order to predict this
correctly
i need to know how often cat
appears in cat appears
around sat as compared to
every other word in the vocabulary so i
need to know
the connection like that the count
let's say c is the count function i need
to know how often does
sat and cat appear together
in this context sorry in context
and i need to divide it by
everything else that the word sat
could hear x by everything else that the
word sat
could appear with right by every other
possible context
now that is not possible usually so
what we do is we do a thing called
negative sampling and in negative
sampling
we simply say something like um
i'm just going to get a bunch of other
contexts that i
randomly sample from from the
from the data set and i'm going to
normalize
this by these randomly sampled data
points
so i'm going to replace the whole of the
denominator
by a randomly sampled subset and that's
going to be
good enough and this is a lot of what
contrastive methods do as well
so if i want to let's say classify
we've seen this a lot yeah with with
these contrastive methods
if i want to classify a data point x
into you know wherever it needs to go um
what i can do instead is i can simply
say well i have a data point
y right here and i know
x and y are somehow related to each
other
so i want to make them close together
and i'm going to simply sample a bunch
of other data points
z1 z2 z3 z4
and i'm going to make those repel each
other
and that's going to be my objective so
instead of comparing
with the whole data set i'm simply going
to subsample
a set of negative samples randomly
and that's going to be my normalization
in
in the denominator maybe something like
this is happening
right here right by subsampling a set of
queries and then simply normalizing over
those
you do have actually an approximation of
the whole distribution so maybe
it's not that bad what they do right
here okay
so those are my thoughts on the nystrom
approximation they do a bunch of
experiments like they here
compare matrices how they
how they look um they do
a complexity analysis and naturally what
you'll have is instead of having the n
squared complexity you basically go down
to an
o of n complexity um you do have
this m quantity quite a bit in here
but since m is way smaller than n
because you usually
select just a small subset of landmarks
uh you get away you get away with just
calling it
o of n they show how
this relates to other transformers
especially the
lin former and the long former in terms
of memory consumption so here you can
see
as you scale up so in 512 sequence
length
the original transformer has 54
megabytes and the nice streamer
the nice trimmer has 35
in this case um
if you select i think the 64 is you know
you select 64
landmarks out of the 512
so it's not a big saving but as you go
up
here you see you can go up to a sequence
length of 8000
where the original transformer will take
10 gigabytes of memory
whereas the nice streamer
only takes 300 megabytes so the scaling
here is very smooth it's quite
linear as you can see and also the time
required to calculate it
gives you a big big speed up
and it's about the same order i would
say here as
maybe the the lean former because
the lean formula also it compresses down
the sequence length through projection
if i
remember correctly however they do
compare
to these other models
in terms of and this i think is the an
interesting result and this is not in
the paper yet it just
was tweeted by one of the authors this
is the result in the
long range arena so this is
sequence tasks where they're constructed
such that
long range dependencies in the text that
you analyze
are of importance and you can see right
here that the
the standard transformer does you know
okay but it has this this big memory
complexity
and the nice streamer is
able to match that performance now we
don't know yet
if the nice streamer here has you know
what kind of settings it has
how much memory is really saved but i
assume
that quite a bit of memory is saved and
it still retains that capability
of doing these long range dependencies
as you can see right
here the other models that um
reduce the complexity of the attention
matrix such as the performer which uses
random fourier features the linformer
which projects down the sequence length
and the
reformer which if i remember correctly
uses locality sensitive hashing
and isn't so that's n log n and not o of
n
they all perform not as well
as always take experiments with a grain
of salt
right here we don't know yet also this
axis isn't you know it's not centered at
zero so it looks more dramatic
than it really is however it is
it these are promising results and also
check out
the uh appendix if you wanna know
a bit more about the math because
so in my opinion you know these kind of
bounds right here
they should be in the paper because
right now the paper just says
you know if you use all the queries and
cookies as landmarks then you're good
but you know what does that give you and
yeah i fully expect this graphic here
also to be part of the paper
because i think that's that's the most
important result of the paper
yeah there is more to the paper but i
don't want to drag this video on forever
thanks for listening if you have any
sort of comments
uh if it was not understandable i
realize we've skipped over
a bunch of things and i rambled a bit
just let me know
and other than that there is a link to
the code right here the code is super
simple
it's just you know what they describe in
the algorithm there is a link
to the supplement i'll leave this all in
the description
and i'll see you next time bye